more than 260 Ukrainian soldiers have
left the as of style steelworks in
mariopol after an assault which lasted
82 days the Russian Ministry of Defense
says that this video shows Ukrainian
soldiers surrendering at the plant Sky
News has verified the location and we
have blurred the faces of alleged
Ukrainian soldiers this is in line with
the Geneva Convention on prisoners of
War
International Affairs editor Dominic
wacko is in kharkiv with more on what
might happen next we know that 264 men
were evacuated from the avastal
steelworks and 53 of them went to a
hospital in the Russian held east of
Ukraine the rest over over 200 around
211 have gone to a different town but
there's a different interpretation of
what has happened depending on which
side you're listening to the Russians
say this was a surrender Vladimir
Putin's the Kremlin says has committed
to them being treated with International
under International standards but a
lawmaker in Moscow said at least some of
them should be executed there's no um
sound I think or evidence from the
Russians at the moment that they're
going to be let go the ukrainians though
say that they have been let out as part
of a prisoner exchange and they say they
had no alternative but for them to be
evacuated because military means of
rescuing them and lifting The Siege on
the plants had come to nothing they've
they've fought this battle for 82 days
against the Russians Sing-Off huge
amount of Firepower artillery airstrikes
and cluster bombs used against them and
against all the odds and I think against
most experts expectations they've
carried on fighting but the ukrainians
are now admitting that that fight is
over so I think the question is what's
going to happen to these Fighters who've
been able to get out but also what
happens to those left behind we still
don't know exactly how many of them
there are I spoke to Natalia zariska
earlier and then she's a wife of one of
the fighters and she doesn't know
whether her husband is one of those
who's been let out or whether he's still
in the bowels of that steel works I
asked her though how she was doing today
we only know the official information we
have now of news uh direct from our
husbands and
we are under the pressure
of waiting
how are you feeling now Natalia
how are you you also replied normally no
changes the last one uh when we keep in
touch was the seventh of May
so you have no idea if he's amongst the
people who've been evacuated today
uh but um at the bottom of my card I
feel that he is okay I don't uh Lose My
Hope
when we spoke last you said that if they
ended up in Russian hands they would
probably be killed are you still worried
about that
Russian occupants to broke all
agreements now the ukrainians say that
the mission that they have been carrying
out for more than 80 days has now been
accomplished that mission they say was
to buy time and to hold down what they
say were twenty thousand Russian troops
who were besieging this plant troops
that they couldn't be used elsewhere in
the donbass so they will now be freed up
the ukrainians though say they are now
trying to evacuate the rest of the
fighters uh in avos as of style and
we'll have to see whether they're
successful and whether they will be
surrendering to the Russians or will
also be part of this prisoner exchange
which the ukrainians say at least was
their agreement with the Russians would
happen